looking for a database service that will  free you up from thankless  administrative and management tasks  Google cloud spanner the horizontally  scalable relational database service  offers industry-leading five nines  availability meaning the database behind  your app has ten times less downtime  than other databases plus it's simple to  deploy and scaling up is as easy as two  clicks automation of complex tasks like  partitioning data across a database and  global synchronous replication are built  in as standard not as expensive add-ons  this frees up your IT resource to focus  on what's important your application  with a simplified pricing model that  removes unnecessary complexity and  Google great security included by  default cloud spanner has all the  ingredients required to simplify  database management with Google Cloud  spanner there's less administration  meaning you can focus on innovation  [Music]